après près de trois semaines à la maison
les français attendent la date du 1er
décembre pour être des confiné une
sortie de confinement qui devrait se
dérouler par paliers selon le premier
ministre jean castex plus vite
j'aime mieux la phase actuelle de
confinement produira ses effets comme
sanitaire j'entends plus nous pourrons
évoluer et passer à une phase suivante
mais mais la cheffe de n'aurez pas votre
question qui ne sera pas le retour à
l'entée confinement c'est à dire que il
y aura des discussions de freinage sont
en cours de calage qui perdure au rang
si la prudence sera de mise lors de ce
retour progressif à la normale les
rassemblements devraient continuer à
être réglementé après le 1er décembre
ce sera également le cas pour le
déplacement qui nécessiteront toujours
des attestations déjà exigé pendant le
confinement lors d'une conférence de
presse à la sortie du conseil des
ministres ce mercredi le porte-parole du
gouvernement a préféré parler d'une
adaptation de confinement plutôt que de
déconfinement il peut y avoir
et c est ce qui est discuté en ce moment
réfléchi travaillé qu'ils pourraient
être annoncés le cas échéant une
adaptation du confinement à partir du
1er décembre des jours qui l'entourent
mais nous ne sommes pas du tout aux
déconfinement on est même loin on parle
d'une adaptation éventuelle du
confinement à partir du 1er décembre si
la situation sanitaire nous le permet
parmi les mesures qui pourraient être
annoncées
la réouverture des commerces non
essentiels ces établissements pourraient
rouvrir avec un protocole sanitaire
renforcée
il en va de même pour les lieux de culte
et la reprise de l'activité sportive en
club pour les mineurs pour le secteur
culturel ainsi que tous les lieux
accueillant du public un nombre maximal
de personnes pourraient être imposées
mais à l'instar des stades où le retour
du public n'aura pas lieu avant 2021 les
salles de spectacle ou de cinéma
pourraient elles aussi être contrainte
d'attendre l'année prochaine enfin bars
et restaurants ne devrait pas voir
d'amélioration pour leur secteur le 1er
décembre prochain
ce n'est probablement qu'en 2021 que ces
établissements pourront également
rouvrir leurs portes
et comme des dizaines
deux restaurateurs en france moi
personnellement je me lève tous les
matins avec eux avec une boule au ventre
chose que je n'avais pas lors du premier
confinement on était encore plein
d'espoir sur une réouverture possible
assez rapide sur la possibilité de
battre ce qu vide rapidement
c'est plus cas aujourd'hui al'approche
de la saison hivernale
les français attendent de savoir s'ils
pourront se déplacer à plus de 100 km
lors des prochaines vacances scolaires
emmanuel macron s'adressera à eux la
semaine prochaine pour faire un point
sur la situation